the ascension of Aegon Targaryen was
confirmed and faith to the Seven
Kingdoms
sealed on the field of fire Kings Loren
Lannister of the rock and Mern gardener
of the reach stood against Aegon's
invasion they commanded a united force
of 600 banners 5,000 mounted knights and
50,000 men at arms Aegon's hosts was
vastly outnumbered and when the army of
the two kings charged the invaders
turned heel and Iran but and all night
was no match for dragon flame when Aegon
unleashed all three of his dragons 4,000
souls were horrendously burned alive on
the battlefield King Mern among
realizing all hope was lost King Loren
surrendered the Starks of Winterfell had
no intention of submitting to Targaryen
rule they had reigned as kings in the
north since the days of the first men
and were determined to resist the
Targaryen invaders just as they had
resisted the and are thousands of years
before King Turan stark led his army to
the renta fork just east of Riverrun
hoping to succeed when Lorne and
murdered failed but when Torrance saw
the size of a God's now mighty host
along with his monstrous dragons he knew
he couldn't subject his followers to the
horror of another failed to fire he bent
the knee and swore fealty to Aegon who
allowed the Starks to maintain their
lordship over the region as Lords
paramount and wardens of the north
without question
Torrence Stark saved thousands of lives
that day
he was ever afternoon as the king who
knelt